so we're gonna do a breakdown of Cassie
and her three variation or to start off
our wonderful Street so beer let's do it
and Brian will discuss it
we're going to start first with so let's
go to the zoo crossroads you know that
Ferb the crossroads really dig that
stream that's alright that's the one we
we showed by the way yeah bodies hanging
every m'kay okay it's classic okay be
sure you don't talk Brian during the
intros I know this otherwise the streams
alright and so we're in here so let's
start off with what's common across all
our variations she has the gunshot all
right yeah and her most inert her main
moves are the gunshots her like flip
kick her she has like a fly on dive kick
they also you can ever projectiles which
is really handy and that's that's pretty
much your common ones yeah and of course
it you we've also got a little bit of
flare also with some of her special
attacks as what we heard normal that's
what kind of little hint of Johnny Cage
Lelouch I don't kick it just to end a
combo it's not really
she needs to primarily use but just kind
of the flavor of where she came it is
definitely a really good string for guys
oh it's one of its one of the ones I go
to quite a bit sure oh yeah and then
exclusive to this variation she's got
air guns as well and then you can do a
right and then of course she's got her
classic nothing say it's dad more than
that no much right right and she'll give
you she'll give you a double punch too
well everyone is it's so funny but all
the tweaks I get and I think it's
hilarious
everyone's like can you get something
extreme who doesn't drop combos it's
funny cuz you think about you hear about
all the tournament players and they're
like every time they're playing like you
get tournament jitters yeah I get stream
jitters knowing that there's ten
thousands of people watching and I'm
going to and use it forever you also
drop combos all the time at your desk
that's it
I do drop covers on my desk quite a bit
yes you do um so that for the most part
is what's unique to this variation so
let's go ahead and go with sunglasses
and of course the song land this one was
this honors right all right go back to
player select and we'll go over in the
next video yeah let's do uh but SpecOps
bye guys I can definitely do let's do uh
you'll probably see a little K no oh
yeah see how they how they have it a
little talk together banter here there's
there some history some fans that
history they're so so rude
baby that swings on me they're all gonna
be on you yeah
absolutely think Brian's gonna be the
one to talk over an intro yeah yeah he
hasn't gotten the Gendler yet but once
you do yeah yeah but no you have your
club closed I was close it was close
all right so with the spec ops version
she has homing drone that she can call
in right and naturally she can do it at
different distances she to do a close
one she can do a full-screen version and
then if you do the iax it actually so
she has a guaranteed pop-up for the most
part with a special move right and then
of course she has the American which is
just an awesome specific sound I'd be
the Tyrolean I keep wanting to ask the
sound Department if I can get a distant
clip of it so every time I get a text
message that would never get annoying I
can't wait to play people who play it as
Cassie and just continue when they're
just whooping your ass yeah just
continue saluting you oh I know it's
gonna happen to me to fruit so um the
most part she keeps a lot of her fight
style stays pretty much the same across
all you're a jeweler yeah there's a
little bit of a difference but for the
most part which is great because once
you learn her combos you can pretty much
just play any variations right I'm gonna
die but you play run away with you know
the Hollywood trade over up an air throw
a lot of bullets around then just do
some zoning for the most part okay this
one I like also because if you start
getting into the run mechanics like this
is a great one for bounce up run run
come oh yeah you got a pop up anywhere
on the screen if you're ready for Ocasio
also is more of a
more of a run based character where she
has doesn't have a straight traditional
pop-up where a lot of our pop-ups are
kind of more of a distance you pop-up it
makes you force you used to run a little
bit more it was just more done in your
facebook with characters yeah we've
definitely seen some really cool road
combos from the guys in QA yeah like
where you're like how do you alright
alright sure you can do that definitely
I just like especially with the the next
one we're gonna show yes brawler like
I've played brawler quite a bit you're
always kind of done to the brawlers I
like this you've got the kid run drummer
yeah I've always played characters who
is grabs and I player well I think that
player pretty well for me but then you
see the guys in QA doing just crazy run
run cancels and in the new stuff it's
pretty awesome
alright you wanna do destroy yeah
lovely little finger mm-hm nice touch
there's a little bit of her father's
flavor hey Humpty Dumpty only a fool
would speak to me thusly
only a dork would say that's okay this
one we have
she has a tackle son tackle that's just
right very USC issue this is new as well
this is just kind of a new renter than
they were give her an extra grapple here
this trade is mostly the bearings been
based off of right she also has this is
this is awesome - you can do this and
the brawler's variant she also has an
air throw right it's nine four other
very you're gonna play with parachute
don't go out of play oh there we go
punching me in the face
oh man oh my YT root ality brutalities
for their lunch so as you just saw we
have